yeah
[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have officially
unveiled the PS plus essential games for
November 2022 and like always I'm here
to Showcase them and tell you a few
details you should know all three games
can be downloaded on PS4 and PS5 from
Tuesday November the 1st if you're ready
let's do this the Lego Harry Potter
collection years one to four and five to
seven by now everyone knows the Lego
formula smash stuff build stuff collect
studs rinse and repeat Lego Harry Potter
has a few tricks off its sleeve but it's
still essentially the same 90 of the
time the real draw of all Lego games is
the tie-in to the brands we know and
love and the World of Harry Potter is
extremely well recreated in Danish
plastic reliving the entire movie series
in short eye-catching missions is a
great experience for fans and with
countless references to find exploration
becomes the most fun especially when
riding on a broom one mechanic unlike
other Lego games is spell casting as
each year passes Harry and and his
friends learn new spells and those who
Grant access to other areas in Hogwarts
so year one Harry can't access some
locations that year 3 Harry can this is
definitely for the Harry Potter fans and
if you're excited for the Hogwarts game
coming next year replaying the movies
with all the charm of Lego is a solid
way to spend your time oh and have fun
unlocking over 200 characters next an
indie game on ps4 and PS5 Heavenly
Bodies a physics-based puzzle game we
play as bumbling astronauts who must fix
the space station and Venture the Galaxy
the thing is there's no gravity up here
so basic things are hilariously
difficult each thumbstick controls an
arm and the shoulder buttons control
grabbing and kicking it's like quap in
space infuriating and funny at the same
time local co-op is supported but sadly
there isn't an official online mode so
if you want to play with a friend over
the interweb you'll need to use share
play not ideal I know but playing
heavenly bodies with another the person
makes the game so much more memorable
Heavenly Bodies is quite a short game
about five hours I'd say depending on
how quick your brain adapts to no
gravity and I've saved the best until
last the sublime neo2 by now we all get
the basic concept of souls like games a
third person RPG shrouded in a dark
fantasy setting with intensely difficult
fights held together by perfect timing
and reactions nail 2's version of this
sends us to Japan in the 1500s we play
as a mute character who has taken a vow
of silence as they battle the endless
war with monsters one really cool thing
about this game have you ever fought
someone in a game and really enjoyed
their moveset and maybe you thought to
yourself I'd like to have that move well
neo2 makes that dream come true after
defeating a foe they have a chance of
dropping a soul core which if we cleanse
it can give us the move you admired on
the battlefield it's a great mechanic
this also adds a level of panic as this
is a Souls like game should we die our
soul cause our drop dropped giving us a
single chance to retrace our steps and
pick it all back up again before it's
lost forever the depth of neo2 is
staggering from the custom character
creator to the Unix Guild trees to
master to the weapon types like melee
weapons there's nine different melee
weapons alone to some Gamers all these
options are great to others it can be
completely overwhelming and paralysis of
choice sets in an average playthrough of
neo2 is about 50 hours long and in that
time a typical player will die hundreds
of times but every death is a lesson so
what do you think of these offerings
delighted sad Furious glad please sound
off in the comments below and rate it
out of 10 I'm giving this month a solid
7 out of 10. what say you I'm Adam
you're awesome I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]